dink think
hello friends do you need to hold hands
yeah we're holding the hands you guys
should be holding hands too
if you have no one to hold hands with
just hold your own hand
or your dog's hand or your cat's hand
hello
i'm here um i haven't been on the
internet for a while
uh i just wanted to come on with julian
and let you guys know this is the end of
the jen and julian podcast and if i
think about it too much and if i say
hear too much i'm probably gonna cry
yeah
and i can't really look at julian
because i'm probably gonna cry
but i wanted to say thank you so much
for okay um all of your support
over however many years we've been doing
this a long time yeah
this is like one of the sources of
so much happiness and laughter and joy
and such a good time
and i'm so glad that so many of you
had such a good time with us and
all good things come to an end and
that's okay and
you know maybe someday in the future
julie and i can do something else
i don't know just it is what it is and i
think
um for now the podcast
is is goodbye it's goodbye
uh yeah thank you to
everyone who's spent time uh
listening and watching and joining our
dink fam
uh from the time it was a secret fam and
we were just live streaming in our new
stream to now when we
um i don't know nearing 300 episodes of
us sitting here and talking and
playing games and uh
you know i i really do i also feel like
it's been
a big source of happiness and fun for me
um
and you know this podcast has spanned
over a long time in my life and a lot of
different
kind of phases of my life and um
it's hard it's hard to say goodbye uh so
yeah the longer
the longer we sit here the the more
messy it's gonna get but um
just the biggest biggest most heartfelt
thank you to
anyone who has ever listened
uh to our podcast um
it's gonna be okay and you know like
jenna said all
good things come to an end and on to the
next thing and um
who knows what that will be um
you know i i did my best in the interim
to do some solo podcasts and if for
those of you who are nice
and supportive of that uh you know means
a lot it really does
uh but yeah it's time it's this time
it's time to end it and um oh yeah
thank you so much and uh kermit kermit
says thank you too
that's him saying thank you in the
background
yeah i i mean there's really not a whole
lot a whole lot else to go over just we
wanted to
both get on here and you hear it from us
and hear our voices and even though you
can't see us we're here we're talking
and
yeah and this is obviously something
that we shared together and
as much as i know all of you guys have
been incredibly respectful of
me and my well-being and my privacy um
you know i i don't want to put that on
julian to be like
all right go tell everyone that we're
ending the podcast this is also my
responsibility and
um i wanted to extend just a true
heartfelt thank you to everyone
that has supported both of us in this
and
i just i had a wonderful time and i
really appreciate
i don't want to say i didn't cry sorry
it's lame
um but we love you guys very much and
yeah great times great times one of my
favorite times is when we played hide
and seek
on a podcast because who does that no
only us
and um we're not deleting the channel or
anything it's just gonna sit here so the
episodes will be
for you to watch uh you know into
eternity
some of them suck some of them are okay
yeah most of them suck
um but on a much more real sense the
ding fam is not
dying you know i stream on twitch almost
every single day i
post videos and we have a lot of fun
over there and i largely consider
the ding fam you know just kind of
in a new spot right now and um even
though we're not going to be saying dink
dink at the start of the podcast and you
won't hear the intro music ever
you know it's it's i still really really
enjoy
all of your company and um if you're
willing you know
i'll be on twitch so that's where you
can find me in the most
i guess in the most similar format that
i
am in right now to a podcast which is on
twitch so
thank you uh thank you all we love you
yeah really i mean i have a million
things that i would love to say but i i
just want you to know that i'm
i'm doing okay i'm getting help and i'm
just
being a person right now so i genuinely
appreciate
all the support and love and the love
that you've given to julian as well
well thank you guys we'll see you later
thanks for uh listening to our podcast
bye would anyone like to cry yeah
i don't know curve now it's like a great
time
appropriate time to cry sign us up for
the good cry man no i only cry during
when i want to cry oh and i you know i
also really want to um
just big big big big thank you to
every single sponsor we've ever had uh
this podcast has been
carried by the sponsors you guys have
been so wonderful and accepting of them
uh but to all the amazing companies who
have
uh shown their support and backed us
over the years thank you from the bottom
of our hearts thank you for choosing to
support our podcast
and good luck to whatever you do in the
future and
yeah yeah but we love you guys
i love you julian i love you jenna oh
you're sweet
it's been fun and uh we'll see you when
we see ya
which i'll see you probably tomorrow
today for you
but um yeah thank you for a great
podcast
ggs all right bye guys bye